many of you are aware that on Khan
Academy we have this neat scratch pad
where you can write programs and you can
visualize things you can draw things you
can create animations and what you might
not be aware of is now you can actually
we've always had the possibility of
spinning off programs creating branches
save doing a save as and building off of
other people's work but now you can
actually discover the other spin-offs
and you can actually vote for the other
spin-offs and so given that we have this
functionality now we thought it would be
fun to launch a challenge to create
games and simulations and scratch pads
and programs that could help the
learning and the rest of Khan Academy
and see what the community can create
and so this is really to announce the
first of these challenges and it's one
associated with statistics so you'll
need a little bit of a statistics
background to understand this and you
might want to look at the statistics
playlist on Khan Academy for some of the
background there's a video here that
gives an overview but it's really to
talk about the idea of a sample variance
and those of you who are familiar with
the idea of sample variance talks about
how do you how do you compute a sample
variance that best estimates a
population variance and there's a
slightly unintuitive thing where you
divide by n minus 1 as opposed to n and
we talked a lot more about it in this
video and so the goal of this challenge
and I just write the description right
over here you've got to write the code
is to create some type of a of a
simulation or some type of visualization
maybe going to maybe taking randomly
generating some type of a population and
then taking multiple samples of it
trying to estimate the true population
variance by taking the sample variance
and showing that when you divide by n
minus 1 it is an unbiased estimator
especially relative to dividing by n or
maybe n minus 2 or anything else and
then to essentially enter into this
challenge and have your code to be
considered as the official or one of the
official ways to visualize this concept
just saves a spin-off and vote for other
people's spin-offs and then we'll be
able to see what people create and
hopefully we'll have a very very very
cool simulation or hopefully multiple
really cool simulations to show people
this idea of why at least experimentally
and
the unbiased estimator is truly unbiased